hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and Jordan Ross hey said it for me thank
God Jordan Ross actually lives in Texas
he's visiting town right now he has a
YouTube channel called cinematix there's
a lot of grey movie discussions analysis
a whole bunch of unique topics on there
I'm telling you guys as a channel worth
checking out it's one of our featured
channels on our main page there's a
reason why it's a damn good channel so
make sure to check it out as soon as you
can I want to do a topic video with this
homeboy over here we are so close I love
it now I'm very comfortable with you
cheek to cheek to cheek tickles I had a
question over at patreon not long ago
how I sort of imagined comic book movies
evolving or how I like them to evolve
yeah that'd be a fun talk to do with
Jordan says he does a lot of comic book
movie coverage over on his channel
today's video is about how we want comic
book movies to evolve down the road to
stay up to date to stay trending or to
do different things
I guess I'll kick this off one of my
favorite concept ideas is to do a little
bit more graphic novel direct
adaptations one thing I've talked about
plenty times is how I've always wanted
to see a Batman year one direct
adaptation of that at one point during
Aronofsky wanted to do an adaptation but
it was totally different
I always thought it'd be cool to do
experimental comic book movies that
don't have to be huge budget like I've
always thought you could do Batman year
one maybe like a fifty million dollar
budget something like Deadpool focus on
Gordon becoming Commissioner Gordon or
building his way up because that also
introduces when Batman comes into Gotham
I thought it'd be cool to do that
version but also you have Batman and
there you'd have Bruce Wayne but you
don't ever make it clear you don't show
images to the audience that Bruce Wayne
and Batman are connected they're the
same person we would know as the
audience that Bruce Wayne and Batman are
connected because we know that to take
the perspective solely from Commissioner
Gordon's I think it'd be cool do a
low-budget same universe type of deal
you get a different actor to play Gordon
or doesn't have to be completely
connected and do direct graphic novel
adaptations I know we do a lot of movies
no one usually takes inspiration from
several materials and then adapt
into one story yeah I think it'd be neat
to do just one direct kind of like what
Sin City did yeah with Italy's or 300
for example like we were saying earlier
two movies that that kind of build their
own universes instead of trying to
conform and like fit within this grander
universe like where they're more focused
on what they're leading up to and the
grand scheme of things instead of
focused on building their own individual
worlds and focusing on the characters
within this one movie that's the other
main thing I really like to do because I
feel like every character even in the
MCU I know we got this giant world that
the MCU is awesome that's like that's
great that's fantastic the thing is I
don't really feel the universe within
the universe I'm always just fully aware
of the bigger universe the grand
University you're talking about with
Batman especially I think that that's a
great opportunity to do that right now
and I feel like they're kind of trying
to do that with all the DC EU films they
have in mind they got like a Nightwing
movie they got a Batgirl movie they got
a solo Batman movie I think one thing
that complet movies could do more of
more than just individual focused films
build the universes within there because
within each one of these characters
spider-man Batman Thor Captain America
any one of them there's a universe there
yeah I would like it if they could hone
in more on that universe that doesn't
mean do solo Joker films now just really
build their own individual universes up
really make their individual storylines
feel like a universe that way when it
crosses over it feels like universes
crossing over
yeah with another universe I agree
whereas right now the only one that
really has it going for that is the
x-men franchise currently because it's
not completely with Disney just yet
[Music]
that's one thing I'm hoping that when
x-men crosses over that they don't lose
that the x-men universe is its own
universe a really defined world and then
you cross it over into the bigger MCU
grand scheme universe yeah I agree
and a cool way they could do that is you
know they have all these Infinity stones
and they can play with Doctor Strange
and Scarlet Witch they can play with all
these different dimensions so there's a
really easy way for them to do that to
build a separate x-men universe and then
cross it over I mean especially because
the the MCU has been getting really
cosmic lately that it wouldn't be much
of a stretch to ya be like oh yeah this
other dimension where there's a whole
bunch of superheroes executives and
stuff like yeah I think that'd be a
really neat idea - in total all I'd
really want for the comic book movies to
evolve into is do more direct graphic
novel adaptations and that way you could
experiment more to get different kinds
of directors on board and really John
rebend it yeah and then really focus
solely not just on an individual movies
but building universes within the
universe yeah that would be the most
exciting concept to me one is we were
talking about in another video was
animated superhero movies like an
spider-verse than the Superman movie
coming out I think that that is a really
interesting route to take because you
know it makes them feel more like comic
books come to life they have big budgets
and really good talent making them
they're amazing like into the
spider-verse
looks incredible the animation looks
great a great voice cast and it has
potential to be one of the best
spider-man movies ever made and it also
kind of opens up the doors to do even
more that you can't do in live-action
films or that's well at least more
difficult to do in live-action films so
I think it would be cool to see some
more animated superhero films that
actually get huge theatrical releases
that aren't just straight to DVD that no
one ever sees except for the die-hard
fans yeah and the other thing is I think
it would be cool to see more period
superhero films that take some different
time because it DC Animated world they
had like Gotham by Gaslight yeah which
is you know Victorian times uh-huh
exactly I think that would be really
cool to explore different eras and
different yeah time periods and within
the superhero genre because a lot of
them are just contemporary they're
taking place modern-day you know they're
fun and they're exciting but there's
only so much you could do in this
current setting like I said I was
talking to Corey Chandra
he had an idea to do a Fantastic Four
movie set in the 60s I mean which would
be really cool maybe do Blade movie
because in the comics blade was born and
though I think late 1920s so you could
do a blade movie set in the 1940s in LA
be cool that would be awesome because it
would be in the middle of World War two
there could be Nazi vampires one of my
favorite comic books I've ever read is
actually CONCACAF at math the real
killer which is all in like it's like
the 40s or 50s but it's a very film noir
and yeah thetic it's the whole bat world
the gallery and everything in the bat
family but it's all in that aesthetic
yeah and I would love to see that
like you don't have to do these movies
that are all about connecting to it's
one universe exactly I think you can get
to a point cuz I know people were like
it's kind of weird having this
standalone Joker film and maybe right
now it is having this standalone Joker
film the reason why that's weird is
because the DC you whatever that
universe is called yeah it's not firmly
established just yeah it hasn't really
found its footing no and I think that's
why having this standalone Joker film
feels off right now but once I think
they get that really underground I think
doing these separate genres or doing
these graphic novel adaptations because
what I was talking about with more than
just individual movies is the method
seems to be that the MCU is really done
well standalone superhero films and then
cross them over eventually to the bigger
picture I'm talking about more than just
a standalone superhero film but building
that universe within there the reason
why I like the Batman your one idea is
because that's a lower budget film it's
not a two hundred million dollar film
it's the million dollar film right there
idea and you can do that with like a
whole bunch of different characters too
if you wanted to go with the smaller
characters or smaller worlds worlds
within worlds yeah two smaller films I
don't have to be these giant massive
blocks and you get that way you put more
focus because you don't have as much
money so you can't do as big of like
these huge action spectacle character
folks yes character focus which like
Logan yes one it focuses on on the
characters more so than a lot of other
superhero movies and I think that is a
really interesting way to go about it
because that would make you care because
a lot of people are saying they're
getting superhero fatigue and all this
stuff that would be a good way to make
you care about these characters a little
bit more than
these heroes that are invincible and
there's a beam coming out of the sky and
you know all the aliens flying down it's
more personal and intimate one thing
that I feel that most MCU films lack or
in the DC films to a big part of
building a universe within a universe is
really establishing its villain super
well I saw Black Panther recently and I
think Eric hill monger is the greatest
MCU villain we've had so far better than
Loki I think he's better than I am yeah
Loki successful he's that rare exception
- yeah I look at spider-man I'm like he
has a whole awesome rogue gal all these
guys have a great roll down like rain
emesis yeah please this big part in
their unit and they're actually how you
build the universe in the universe and
then with Batman he's got the bat family
that's oh I'm like pretty intrigued
about what Warner Brothers is trying to
do right now yeah it's all about timing
and allowing it to grow and evolve there
but be patient because a lot of
comic-book movies especially after
marble because marble has been patient
you know they're the ones that started
this whole sure you know many wars been
taking a long time yeah taking their
time we're invested we care about these
characters all these other you know
properties like DC and other superheroes
I think they need to do a better job at
being patient and building the
groundwork instead of being like oh we
have to catch up with Marvel let's just
throw it all in this one movie I think
that would play a big part in the future
of superhero me the other thing - I like
more of and I feel like we again
referencing the x-men franchise crossing
genres more yeah I feel like Marvel does
a pretty good job at subtle crossover
John Rizzo yeah a man's like a heist
film Winter Soldier is like a spy
thriller yeah space opera be some
regards yeah like they do a good job at
that sometimes they're more subtle than
others and then you know spider-man
homecoming is like a teen high school
yes Johnny hey you know what I haven't
seen with x-men is I've really been
doing full-heartedly different jobs like
a horror awaken exactly our Deadpool
being just a full long comedy yeah
exactly doing stuff like that I think
would be cool to experiment with our
heroes I agree really really John Robb
ended a hell of a lot more and I think
when you do period pieces that genre
bends it along exactly like imagine one
thing with I think it was in x-men
origins where it showed flashbacks of
Wolverine fighting in World War 2 and
all this yet why couldn't they have done
a movie that takes place during yeah
with Wolverine my
would have been that would have been
neat instead of just a mantra what do
like go back even further and do stuff
like set into 1800s or the 1700s that
would add something fresh to the
superhero genre League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen kind of tried to do that it
was a bad movie you know something like
that at a concept is cool yeah you can
do I want a League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen Netflix series that would be I
think it would be real and like dark and
gritty but like set in that time period
would be really cool I think in some
ways this shows or is cooler than the
movie yes and that that's kind of like
the future of I think the superhero is
on there as well as TV shows I think
we're gonna get a lot more TV show yeah
because more money is being thrown at TV
shows more than ever it seems like the
creative freedom goes more to TV shows
now and there's there's more TV than
ever before so I think the future will
have more TV shows for our bigger heroes
to you because networks are gonna have
to get their own superhero shows to
compete because exactly like all like
Netflix and Hulu and all of these you
know which are already doing yeah yeah
they all have these superhero shows I
think that's definitely gonna play a big
part in the future of this genre what
ideas would you have for how you'd want
comic book movies in general to evolve
please put them in the comment boxes
below engagement let us know we think of
our ideas that can I hate me that's true
you should be used to it by now though
no no it still stings every time yeah
I'm this much closer to killing myself
okay subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification about get notified
every time one of our videos is out and
check out our patreon a lot of exclusive
videos over the Eric fact this video
idea was created because of someone
asking us a question on patreon weekly
Q&A is over there last but not least
make sure to check out Jordan Ross on
the cinematix YouTube channel gonna
shoot a video for his channel with him
right now make sure to check it out a
lot of great movie topics on there a lot
of complicated stuff on there too go
subscribe right away what he said